what's up guys let's go let's go up to
the beginning and do another run there
oh my god what's up guys today we're at
our favorite place
Hollywood Sports Park we're here to
shoot again but this time it's with a
drum
[Music]
nice work today we're shooting top-down
shooter it is a really really cool one
take video that's all going to be filmed
above the map from a drone so not only
is there going to be a lot of
choreography on the ground that we have
to go through and memorize but there's
choreography with the camera in the air
that we have to memorize and that's what
makes this shoot so unique then
basically it begins and so here we see
our good guy gets in there nice a guy
another guy is coming through that room
knocks mouth throws on the ground goes
into the next ring shoots that guy busts
into this next screen choose two more
guys sneaks in behind the person who's a
shot throws him onto the table our hero
grabs one of guns there's a gunpoint
happen in between these two rooms and he
decides to flank them anklet good now so
you guys who our patreon supporters
might remember this is actually one of
the tears that we had on patreon her
top-down shooter video is on our patreon
page for the $10,000 mark and we're
actually going to be doing this video
before we reach that and for one
particular reason if you remember our
Superman with the GoPro video
it was shot on a phantom - and the
Phantom - is made by DJI they are going
to be working with us today to shoot
this video we have a s900 from DJI which
is a top tier drone flying at gh4 so
we're upgrading from the Phantom 2 and
taking it up another level I got sand of
my peat now you can turn use this as
little as possible here we go all right
everybody all right guys let's have
everyone reset getting it into position
okay oh crap
[ __ ] sloppy what's on them do better
there's so much easier than yelling so I
get a quick shout out to octave films
they are they are helping us set the
thing up and fly it today well I don't
leave it let me do this
first you're literally going to fly okay
cool we're on let me see
stylist Jen can take it off glamour yeah
true pros they flew a drone into a Sun
roof of a car traveling 45 miles an hour
and back out over and over and over did
that good
Luzi home oh [ __ ] elbow to the boob oh
it doesn't actually have to touch oh
that needs to be over your boobs all
right cool
if at any point you panic don't try and
drop your controller don't try to do it
all right no attempts will be made
oh wow slam
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that way
[Music]
oh hey hello there welcome to the end of
the behind-the-scenes four top-down
shooter as you can see it was a really
really fun shoot surprisingly low stress
compared to our other shoots because you
can land like two shots we only had like
two shots to get those you filmmakers
out there looking drones highly
recommend you check out that sign
hundred or the Phantom two if you want
to kind of get your feet wet before
jumping all in check out DJI check out
their stuff they make incredible film
tools some our biggest videos this year
have been shot with their stuff so yeah
yeah and once again this video and many
more that we'll be releasing this vault
would not be possible without our
supporters on patreon so we really thank
you guys for helping us put this kind of
stuff together also once again Hollywood
sports bar keeps thanks to them as well
they're awesome yeah and last but not
least our friends and crew who came out
to help us out you guys know who you are
thanks so much this video would not be
possible without you guys alright see ya
[Music]
I got it